it looks like a lunar landscape
Demetriou Leon teok has come here to
survey the damage he's an environmental
activist and belongs to the pro-european
out of Maidan movement the craters here
are the result of amber mining the
company responsible was supposed to have
reforested the land that clearly hasn't
happened instead new craters have
appeared it was probably illegal
Amba diggers who took advantage of the
opportunity or bribed the police who
guard the area the activist meets a
group of men nearby in the village of
class Eve in northwestern Ukraine
eventually they agreed to show him the
fruits of their mining activities
possession of illegally mined amber can
lead to prosecution in Ukraine this
small heap of stones could fetch one
thousand US dollars on the black market
the men say that the gem stone is
especially sought-after by Chinese
buyers
the illegal mining has been a financial
boon for the village where the money's
been used to build houses the men
responsible say they're doing the local
area a favor they've been able to build
a playground and there are plans to
improve the roads too Vasil maintains
the government is aware of and even
cashes in on illegal mining mining is
good business for the guys at the top
too the bureaucrats don't have to invest
anything and still end up better off
he's referring to bribes the miners say
police officers and security officials
turn a blind eye to the illegal
activities in exchange for cash payments
Dimitri Leone's York wants to change
that he says huge areas are being
destroyed by illegal mining we're
talking about thousands or even hundreds
of thousands of people who are mining
Amba in the forest
it's totally chaotic there's no system
in place there's evidence to back up the
claim this aerial footage shot by a
group of activists gives an indication
of the extent of the damage the illegal
miners are using pumps to wash the amber
towards the surface they plumb to a
depth of 20 meters the fracking is a
huge earner Demetriou Lyon teok and the
other activists managed to film the
illegal mining with their cell phones
the footage shows miners almost
resembling worker ants labouring hard it
said that installing a pump costs around
six hundred dollars in bribes that
ensures the authorities turn a blind eye
and this is what the landscape looks
like after the illegal miners have left
the areas around the mine have become
barren that's the really terrible thing
the amber miners don't do anything about
it they should at least reforest the
area but that's not happening the
government in Kiev appears to be
displaying a less a fair attitude to the
environmental damage occurring in the
northwest of the country occasionally
there is a crackdown though Demetrio
Lian teok has got a tip about a raid in
an amber grinding facility in the city
of Riva 'the the police officer tells
Demetriou the machines are to be
confiscated that will lead to a court
hearing and the machines will be
returned that's always what happens
some accused the courts of taking bribes
to the factory manager insists his
operations are all aboveboard instead he
says he's been targeted by raids because
he refused to pay bribes to the
authorities it's impossible to abide by
the law here they want to force us to
partake in an illegal economy
but the businessman does admit that he
skirts around the law in other respects
he says there's no way of buying amber
in Ukraine legally so he has to look
elsewhere
I bought the amber in Poland so I could
start work
that said it's still Ukrainian amber
probably smuggled to Poland under the
eyes of the authorities says Demetriou
Leon took sales of the final product
fetched billions on the global market
especially in Europe and China
Dmitry Leon CEO can understand why the
many impoverished people from this
region feel entitled to a piece of the
pie especially given that the amber is
literally beneath their feet mining
could be legalized and we could organize
it in such a way that everyone can
profit a cooperative with ten to fifteen
residents would have enough work for two
or three years mine the area they should
then refill the holes plant trees and
reforest the area
Dimitra leon sook envisions a system in
which the money generated from mining
would stay in the area and not end up in
the hands of corrupt officials